Cristiano Ronaldo is the first soccer
player to surpass 1 billion dollars in
career earnings the first team sport
athlete to reach this milestone only two
athletes have crossed this threshold
while still active in their sport Tiger
Woods in 2009 and Floyd Mayweather in
2017 Ronaldo made 65% of his total
career earnings from his work on the
field commanding the highest salary on
his club every year since 2007 this past
year he made 60 million dollars
including the 30 percent pay cut he
agreed to take after the corona virus
pandemic forced Italy's Ligue 1 to shut
down had he earned his full salary he
would have ranked number one on the
highest-paid athletes list in 2020 ahead
of Roger Federer but the man who goes by
the trademark cr7 built his own
lifestyle empire that currently accounts
for a quarter of his endorsement income
and it's on the rise
his branded line of underwear first
launched in 2013 followed by a line of
shoes fragrances and denim in addition
to his own line he also pitches products
head to toe in return for forty five
million dollars a year
his biggest sponsor Nike signed him to a
lifetime deal worth 1 billion dollars in
2016 making him just the third athlete
after Michael Jordan and LeBron James
hitched to the swoosh for eternity and
it's not all close in 2015 he entered
the hotel business with Portugal's
Pastrana hotel group the first hotel
opened a year later in his hometown of
Funchal medina on top of his museo cr7 a
shrine for his trophies and a retail
outlet for his signature goods he also
entered the health club industry with
crunch to open cr7 gyms he was the first
account to hit 200 million followers on
Instagram in January 2020 and is now the
most followed athlete on social media
with 427 million followers across
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where a simple photo of a new hairstyle
can get over 400,000 likes off the field
and on the field he's making serious
money setting the bar as the sport's top
earner
for now
you
[Music]
[Applause]